Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast von ESA und DLR. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle hier zur 43. Ausgabe. Ich war in den letzten Ausgaben in Italien. Mittlerweile bin ich wieder zurückgekehrt und bin ein weiteres Mal nach Darmstadt gefahren zum ESOC der ESA, um ein nach viel Erdbeobachtungsthemen jetzt mal wieder eine etwas fernere Mission in Augenschein zu nehmen. Wir wollen uns ja hier ohnehin in den nächsten Ausgaben noch weiter mit den Planeten unseres Sonnensystems beschäftigen und genau um einen solchen geht es auch hier. Konkreter geht es um eine Mission zu diesen Planeten, nämlich zum Planeten Merkur. Die Mission BepiColombo steht in wenigen Jahren an, ist also eine zukünftige Mission und damit beschäftigt sich vor allem Elsa Montagnon. Herzlich willkommen bei Raumzeit. Du bist die Flugleiterin von BepiColombo, von dem Projekt, was glaube ich im August 2015 dann voraussichtlich die Erde verlassen wird. Zu dir, also wie lange bist du schon hier bei der ESA?
Ich bin seit 13 Jahren bei der ESA. Ich bin in 99 angekommen hier.
Und welchen Ausbildungsweg hast du bis dahin beschritten, um dann zur ESA zu kommen?
Ich habe Maschinenbau studiert und zwar in Frankreich und dann in Deutschland für ein paar Jahre. Ich bin ja Französin, man hört das. Und dann hat mich die Raumfahrt immer schon sehr interessiert, schon in der Zeit. Und ich habe während meines Studiums Kontakt zur ESA bekommen und bin hierher gekommen nach Darmstadt und ich fand das sehr interessant und total toll.
Jetzt geht ja Maschinenbau nicht unbedingt als so das klassische Raumfahrt-Vorbereitungsprogramm, oder?
Ich kann es nicht genau sagen. Also für mich gab es diese Spezialisierung im Maschinenbaubereich und Raumfahrtechnik in München und das war genau das Richtige für mich und hat mich hierher gebracht sozusagen.
Das heißt, die Faszination Raumfahrt war auch schon vorher vorhanden?
Ja, ich fand immer fliegenden Maschinen sehr, sehr interessant und vor allem Satellitern, wir sind die Christopher-Columbus der Neuzeit sozusagen, das sind so Schiffe, die jetzt die richtigen Abenteuer führen und das finde ich ganz toll.
Das heißt, dann bist du relativ früh gleich zur ESA gewechselt, da warst du schon sehr lange dabei. Was hat dann dazu geführt, dass du hier zum ESA-Og gewechselt bist?
Also wie gesagt, während meines Studiums habe ich Kontakt zur ESA-Og bekommen und ich fand dieses Zentrum sehr interessant, technisch und menschlich. Deswegen bin ich eingestiegen und habe die Chance gehabt, eine Stelle als Young Graduate Trainee zu haben. Das ist ein Programm der ESA für junge Diplomanten, also direkt nach dem Diplom. Das gibt es noch heute und es ist eine tolle Möglichkeit, da einzusteigen. Das habe ich mitgemacht. Ich war damals im Team der Mission Rosetta, die Kometen-Mission der ESA. Ich hatte dann die zweite Chance, direkt am Ende von diesem Programm eine Stelle zu bekommen. Ich bin dann geblieben. Immer noch im Rosetta-Team, also im Flugkontrollteam. Ich habe den Start mitgemacht in 2004 und seit 2007 bin ich zu BepiColombo gewechselt, diesmal in der Stelle von der Flugleiterin.
Zu Rosetta und auch dem vorhergehenden Projekt Ciotto hatten wir hier auch schon mal eine Sendung, nämlich Raumzeit Nummer 20. Da habe ich mich mit Gerhard Schwim unterhalten, der Mission-Manager von Rosetta. Wer Lust hat, sich da noch mal ein bisschen zu vertiefen, kann da mal reinhören. Ja, BepiColombo ist eine Mission zum Merkur. Was war da die Motivation der ESA, diese Mission aufzunehmen?
Merkur ist ein bisschen der verlorene Planet. Das ist ein von den Planeten im nahen Sonnensystem, das sehr wenig besucht worden ist. Es gab mal eine amerikanische Mission in den 70er Jahren, die drei Vorbeiflüge gemacht hat an Merkur. Das war die Mariner 10 in 1974, 1975. Seit letztes Jahr gibt es endlich wieder eine amerikanische Mission im Orbit an Merkur. Wir bekommen jetzt Daten von dieser Mission, die faszinierend sind. Damals dachten wir, dass es ein gutes Projekt wäre, da hinzugehen. Merkur gibt auch noch ein Schlüssel zum Studium vom Sonnensystem, wie das aufgebaut worden ist, wie Planeten entstehen, was für gute Bedingungen zum Leben sind. Zu diesem Planeten wussten wir sehr wenig. Wir wissen mehr über Mars und Venus, aber Merkur war eher unbekannt.
Waren die Mariner-Missionen die ersten Missionen überhaupt zu Merkur?
Ja, Mariner 10 war die erste überhaupt.
Was waren denn das für Beobachtungen, die da gemacht wurden?
Die sind vorbeigeflogen mit ein paar Instrumenten. Da kenne ich mich nicht genau aus, aber Kameras waren auf jeden Fall dabei. Die haben dann das Ganze kartiert, so eine Karte erstellt, aber nicht ganz, weil das nur kurze Vorbeiflügen waren. Die konnten nur 45 Prozent der gesamte Oberfläche kartieren. Und das mit einer Genauigkeit, die wir jetzt sehr gut verbessern können mit den Maschinen, die in Orbit sind. Also Messenger und dann später BepiColombo.
Das heißt, Messenger war jetzt eine zweite Mission?
Messenger ist die zweite und BepiColombo wird die dritte sein. Und ich weiß nicht, dass es noch schon eine vierte gibt.
Okay, also noch ein wirklich wenig besuchter Planet. Messenger war auch eine NASA-Mission. Das heißt, das ist jetzt überhaupt das erste Mal, dass sich die ESA mit dem Merkur beschäftigt.
Genau, also BepiColombo ist die erste ESA-Mission zu Merkur überhaupt.
Wie läuft denn das konkret ab? Ich meine, es gibt natürlich Interesse an vielen Missionen. Wissenschaftler wollen alles Mögliche untersuchen. Was war jetzt die konkrete, oder wahrscheinlich gab es eine Reihe von Gründen, aber was war jetzt sozusagen der Auslöser letztlich, sich dann für eine Merkur-Mission zu entscheiden?
Also damals, die Mission ist ungefähr im Jahr 2000 aus der Welt geworden. Also das heißt, schon ziemlich lange Zeit her. Und ich war nicht dabei. Ich kann nicht genau sagen, was der wichtigste Auslöser war. Aber ich denke, die wissenschaftliche Gemeinschaft hat sehr große Interesse auf so einen System Planeten, die gut erreichbar sind von hier. Also man möchte auch Jupiter, Saturn und den anderen besichtigen, aber das ist schwieriger von Technologiestandpunkt. Und wie gesagt, die ESA war noch nie zu Merkur gegangen, aber dafür zu Mars und zu Venus. Und ich denke, da gab es eine Motivation, dieser einzige Planet, der am nächsten zur Sonne ist, von dem man so wenig weiß, sozusagen. Es gab eine große Motivation, das zu erkunden und zu sehen, inwiefern das sich unterscheidet von den anderen Planeten, die man ein bisschen besser kennt.
Wenn das jetzt überhaupt erst die dritte Mission ist, was war denn bisher der Grund, dass so wenig Interesse am Merkur existierte?
Ich glaube, das ist nicht unbedingt eine Frage des Interesses. Das ist auch sehr schwierig. Merkur ist ja sehr schwer zu beobachten, schon vom Boden. Von der Erde aus kann man manche Teleskopen gar nicht in die Richtung Merkur richten, weil das so nah an der Sonne ist. Man kann das überhaupt für ungefähr zwei Stunden, wenn Sonnenaufgang und die Sonne kommen, also an den beiden Seiten vom Tag, Das ist quasi eine Dämmerung, ja. Das ist nur für ein paar Stunden möglich, das zu beobachten. Das war immer ein Problem sozusagen. Man kann das nicht so gut beobachten wie andere Körper im Himmel. Und von der Technik ist es auch sehr schwer, weil Merkur ist so nah an der Sonne, also das ist ein Drittel ungefähr der Distanz zwischen Sonne und Erde, dieser Abstand, man nennt das Astronomische Einheit, also EU. Und die Erde befindet sich ein Astronomische Einheit weg von der Sonne, und Merkur ist 0,3, also sehr, sehr nah. Und diese Energie, die von der Sonne kommt, das muss die Maschine, die Sonder, die das besucht, auch übertreiben können, das muss es übernehmen können.
Ja, das darf sich nicht aufhitzen, sonst würde es ja einfach wegglühen.
Also als Beispiel, die Oberfläche von Merkur hat eine Temperatur auf der sonnigen Seite am Tag von ungefähr 450 Grad Celsius. Das ist genauso heiß wie im Pizza. Also für den Pizza-Hofen. Das ist sehr sehr heiß. Und man braucht dafür Materialien auf der externe Fläche vom Satellit, die das überhaupt überleben können. Das ist gar nicht so leicht. Das andere kommt noch dazu, es ist nicht so einfach, wenn man sich im Sonnensystem reist, also wenn man da fliegt, es ist nicht so einfach in der Richtung von der Sonne zu gehen. Weil die Attraktion von der Sonne ist so groß, aber man möchte ja nicht zur Sonne, man möchte zu Merkur, was neben der Sonne ist.
Also die Gravitation, die Anziehungskraft.
Das ist so stark, dass man da bestimmte Techniken benutzen muss und das macht den Satellit auch sehr komplex. Und ich denke, das war wirklich eine Frage, nicht nur des Interesses, aber vielleicht auch der Technik, das so lange gewartet hat.
Also nicht nur der Merkur ist interessant, sondern es ist auch interessant und eine Herausforderung, überhaupt den Weg zu einem solchen Planeten zu finden.
Auf jeden Fall. Also BepiColombo hat sehr viele neue Technologien entwickeln müssen, sodass wir überhaupt dahin gehen können. Also alles, was alle Oberflächen, die außerhalb von Satelliten sind, sind praktisch neu entwickelt worden für dieses Projekt.
Was ist denn jetzt das eigentliche Missionsziel? Also was soll BepiColombo tun?
BepiColombo soll Merkur erkundigen. Und dafür gehen wir mit zwei wissenschaftlichen Satelliten, die komplementar sind. Der eine ist europäisch und wird relativ nah an Planeten fliegen. Der nächste Punkt wird 400 Kilometer sein bis 1500. Es ergibt sich eine Orbit, eine Bahn. Wir tragen dann Instrumente, z.B. Kameras und Spektrometers, die das ganze Oberfläche sehr gut erkundigen können und auch Messungen für bestimmte Partikel machen können. Und wir bringen dahin auch einen japanischen Satellit von der japanischen Raumfahrtagentur JAXA. Der wird ein bisschen weiter wegfliegen, also auch eine elliptische Orbit, aber eine längere, also den selben Punkt am nächsten vom Planeten, 400 Kilometer, aber weiter weg, also eine größere Ellipse, sodass er sich auf Magnetfeldermessungen konzentrieren kann. Das war eine große Überraschung eigentlich an Merkur, wenn Mariner 10 entdeckt hat, dass es ein Magnetfeld hat, ähnlich wie die Erde. Das ist nicht so stark wie der am Erde, aber er existiert, und das ist eine Einzelheit im Sonnensystem. Mars und Venus haben kein Magnetfeld. Das war wirklich eine Überraschung, und man möchte das besser verstehen und besser charakterisieren, dieses Magnetfeld. Das werden diese zwei Satelliten dann Komplementarmessungen machen können, sodass man ein besseres Bild vom gesamten Planeten haben kann.
Das heißt, an der Stelle ist der Merkur schon deshalb von Interesse, weil er in der Hinsicht der Erde wiederum sehr ähnlich ist.
Ja, also das ist eine Charakteristik, wo sich die Erde ein bisschen ähnlich ist. Es gibt andere, wo er sehr unterschiedlich ist. Es ist ein kleiner Planet, es ist sehr dicht allgemein, es hat keine Atmosphäre, es hat eine sehr dünne Exosphäre. Aber das ist sehr dünn, das kann man nicht mit der Erde vergleichen. Das heißt, dass der Effekt von Sonne und die Partikel, die von Sonne aus rausgespuckt werden, diesen Sonnenwind, es kommt direkt an der Merkur-Oberfläche. Dadurch entstehen auch sehr interessante dynamische Prozesse, wo Teile von der Oberfläche praktisch rausgenommen werden von diesem Sonnenwind.
Und deswegen soll BepiColombo unter anderem dann auch die Partikel einsammeln?
Genau, das ist eine Sache, die BepiColombo auch untersuchen wird. Das heißt, sputtering ist das technische Wort.
Aber geht man davon aus, dass das Magnetfeld der Erde diesen Sonnenwind auch sehr effizient um die Erde herum lenkt, was ja dann überhaupt erst die Ausbildung der Atmosphäre ermöglicht hat. Das heißt, das Magnetfeld beim Merkur ist vermutlich nicht so stark.
Es ist nicht so stark, nee.
Aber ähnliche Effekte kann man schon erwarten, weiß man nicht.
Weiß man nicht. Also ich meine, der Messenger ist jetzt da, die bekommen jetzt Daten und haben ein paar Papiere schon veröffentlicht. Und ich bin sicher, die wissenschaftliche Gemeinschaft guckt sich diese neuen Daten mit sehr viel Neugier an. Weil es gibt viele Fragen, die unbeantwortet sind.
Ja, das ist interessant. Das heißt, Messenger ist 2004 gestartet, war dann 7 Jahre unterwegs und ist jetzt überhaupt erst mal seit einem Jahr ein paar zerquetschte da unterwegs. Das heißt, jetzt zu diesem Zeitpunkt unmittelbar vor dem Start gewinnt man überhaupt erst bestimmte neue Erkenntnisse, die ja dann vielleicht auch kurzfristig dann auch nochmal bei BepiColombo, bzw. auch langfristig, weil auch BepiColombo wird ja einige Jahre unterwegs sein, die dann gegebenenfalls noch einfließen müssen in das Projekt.
Ja, das ist sehr interessant, diese Spiele, kann man sagen, zwischen den zwei Missionen, weil, wie eben gesagt, Messenger ist ja schon da, aber Messenger hat andere Charakteristiken als BepiColombo. Es fliegt nicht so nah an dem Planeten. Es wurde schneller gebaut als BepiColombo, das kann man schon sagen, sodass die Mission dann sehr relativ, also früher starten und dann ankommen konnte, was sehr gut ist, aber dafür sind ein paar technische Wahlen getroffen worden, dass das überhaupt so schnell geht. Also der Design von Messenger ist sehr unterschiedlich von dem von BepiColombo. Und das ermöglicht dann zum Beispiel im Moment sehr gute Beobachtungen am Nordpol von Merkur, aber nicht so am Südpol zum Beispiel. Wobei BepiColombo mit den Eigenschaften vom Satelliten selbst und die Eigenschaften von der Referenzorbit, die wir anziehen, wird dann die Möglichkeit haben, an beiden Seiten von Planeten gute Beobachtungen in derselben Genauigkeit aufnehmen zu können. Das ist sehr interessant, weil Messenger vielleicht ein paar Fragen die Marinart 10 gestellt hatte, aber dafür stellt er neue, die er selber nicht unbedingt antworten kann. Und da kommt BepiColombo ins Spiel. Eine andere wichtige Aufgabe von Messenger für uns, eigentlich für BepiColombo, ist die Charakterisation vom Gravitationsfeld von Merkur. Das ist von Marina nicht so gut berechnet worden. Drei Vorbeiflüge reichen für so etwas überhaupt nicht. Aber seit Messenger in Orbit ist, kann man sehr genaue Messungen machen und dann dieses Gravitationsfeld viel genauer berechnen. Das ist sehr wichtig für uns, denn dadurch kann man die Evolution von der Bahn, vom Satellit um den Planeten, sehr viel präziser vorhersehen. Das heißt, man kann dann den Orbit, wo man den Satellit stellt, ganz am Anfang besser bestimmen, in der voller Gewissheit, wie er sich dann bemitizieren wird.
Das heißt, der genaue Weg steht noch gar nicht fest?
Der genaue Weg dahin steht fest. Wo wir den Satellit richtig einstellen werden, das ist jetzt im Moment besprochen durch die Ergebnisse von MESSENGER. Wir hatten das erwartet. Das war eine der Sachen, worauf wir sehr scharf gewartet haben. Weil das für uns sehr wichtig ist. Dadurch wissen wir wirklich, zum Beispiel abhängend von manchen von diesen Koeffizienten, wird der Bahn sich so ändern, dass der Satellit näher am Planet kommt. Wir haben gesagt, das ist ja sehr heiß. Das heißt, unser Satellit wird nicht unbedingt für solche Temperaturen gebaut. Wir möchten, dass er so lange wie möglich überlebt, dass man gute wissenschaftliche Daten sammeln kann. Das ist nur möglich, wenn man weiß, in welche Richtung sich der Bahn bewegt, wenn man da ist. Wir werden nicht die Möglichkeit haben, die Bahn zu kontrollieren nach der Initiation. Nachdem wir diese erste Bahn, wo wir angekommen sind, wird die Evolution dann von selber gehen. Wir können das nicht mehr beeinflussen. Deswegen ist es sehr wichtig, das zu wissen.
Einmal muss man sich auf irgendwas einigen, dann wird er eingeschossen und dann war es das. Genau. Jetzt hast du ja erwähnt, dass JAXA da auch mit im Boot ist. Und dass ja BepiColombo im Prinzip zwei Satelliten sind in einer Mission. Das heißt, sie werden gemeinsam gestartet, fliegen da gemeinsam hin. Und dann gibt es eine Separation kurz bevor jeder so seine eigene Wege geht. Das ist ja eigentlich auch was Neues, oder? Dass so eine Mission von zwei Agenturen mit unterschiedlichen...
Es gibt viele Beispiele in der Raumfahrtgeschichte. Also zum Beispiel Cassini-Huygens ist eins. Das hat man schon gemacht. Genau, mit Japan hatten wir diese Erfahrung noch nicht in der ESA. Und ich glaube auch für uns in der Welt der Operations, die wirklich diesen Flug mitmachen und beeinflussen werden, es ist auch wichtig zu verstehen, dass der japanische Satellit nicht so klein ist im Vergleich mit dem europäischen. Also wenn diese zwei zusammen sind, der Ratio zwischen den zwei Maschinen ist nicht so groß. Bei Cassini-Holgens zum Beispiel war Holgens sehr gering im Vergleich mit Cassini. Es ergeben sich dadurch unterschiedliche dynamische Prozesse bei der Separation selber. Das ist schon auch ein technischer Challenge, diese Art und Weise nach Merkur zu gehen. Wir haben eigentlich nicht nur zwei Satelliten, wir haben zwei wissenschaftliche Satelliten, aber der Gesamtsatellit besteht aus insgesamt vier Modulen. Die zwei wissenschaftliche Satelliten und dann haben wir noch ein Propulsion-Modul, die elektrische Propulsion und chemische Propulsion, die wir für den Flug dahin brauchen, für diese sechs Jahre bis zur Ankunft, das wird von diesem separaten Modul getragen, der seine eigenen Sonnenflügel hat, weil die elektrische Propulsion ja sehr viel elektrische Energie braucht. Dieses Modul wird dann kurz bevor wir in die Umlaufbahn von Merkur von Gravitationseffekten angezogen werden, es wird dann weggeschoben und er lebt dann sein eigenes Leben, wenn man so sagen kann. Dann gehen wir in die Umlaufbahn mit nur die zwei wissenschaftlichen Satelliten und noch eine mechanische Struktur, die den japanischen Satellit im Flug dahin schützt vor der Sonne. Der japanische Satellit ist ja ein Spinner, er wird um seine eigene Axis rotieren und er kann die Energie von der Sonne von einer einzigen Richtung nicht überleben. Er braucht wirklich diese Rotation, um das durchzuhalten. Im Cruise, also im Flug bis zu Merkur, in diesen sechs Jahren, ist unser Satellit immer in eine gewisse Richtung orientiert. Das ist seine eigene Art zu operieren. Wir können diese Rotation nicht anbieten. Deswegen haben wir eine mechanische Struktur, die dieses Satellit von der Sonne schützt.
Das heißt, das ist das vierte Modul, von dem du jetzt gesprochen hast. Also es gibt das Schutzschild, die beiden Satelliten selbst, und das Antriebsmodul, was selber wiederum zwei Komponenten hat, eine elektrische Komponente und eine chemische Komponente.
Ja, und ein paar elektrische, also er hat diese Sonnenzellen und die elektrischen Boxen, die das alles betreiben und die Interfaces anbieten. Aber an sich, das ist wirklich ein Antriebsmodul.
Ist das jetzt so ungewöhnlich, so ein modularer Aufbau?
Ja, ich würde sagen ja. Also das hat man nicht so oft. Also wenn man die anderen Missionen der ESA, interplanetärische Missionen der ESA anschaut, oder die amerikanischen Missionen, die unterwegs sind, die meisten bestehen auf eine einzige Struktur. Und dann gibt es manchmal einen Lander oder eine kleine Sonde, die separiert wird. Wie zum Beispiel im Fall von Huygens und Cassini, oder im Fall von Rosetta, da gibt es auch einen Lander, der auf dem Komet landen wird. Aber das ist dann eher ein kleiner, sehr kleiner Teil von der Gesamtstruktur.
Heißt das, dass die Satelliten selber keine eigenen Antrieb mehr haben für Korrekturen, oder haben die auch noch kleine?
Die BepiColombo-Satelliten selber, also der europäische hat seine eigene Antriebsstruktur, also chemisch, weil er, er wird dann, wenn der andere Antriebsmodul weg ist, ist er der, der das gesamte Komposit, was noch da ist, ins Umlaufbahn und die gesamte Bahn kontrolliert, bis wir zur Zielbahn angekommen sind. Also er bringt das gesamte Komposit runter bis zum Referenzbahn von dem japanischen Satellit, dem MMO. Und dann wird der separiert und dann gehen wir noch ein bisschen runter und lassen die Schutzstruktur weg. Und dann gehen wir noch, dann machen wir Manöver, sodass wir in unseren eigenen Staat fahren.
Okay, das heißt, es gibt eigentlich zwei Antriebssysteme, einerseits das Antriebssystem als eigenes Modul, was die gesamte Mission überhaupt erstmal in Richtung Merkur bringt. Dann ist die Schuldigkeit getan, das wird abgesprengt. Und dann ist es der ESA-Hauptsatellit, der dann noch Antrieb hat, der den Japaner im Huckepack hat und auch noch in die richtige Richtung wirft und dann eben noch mal für die eigene Bahn und dann ist auch gut. Aber das ist dann noch in Betrieb, man kann das auch nachträglich noch korrigieren und man kann sich damit auch im Orbit halten.
Also bis wir zur Referenzbahn sind, können wir noch Korrekturen machen. Aber dann, wir möchten unsere Instrumente, also das Problem ist, dieses chemisches Zeug, das zum Antrieb benutzt wird, das ist nicht so gut für die Instrumente.
Weil es stoßweise dann entspricht mit Entschütterung.
Also es sprengt Partikel und das ist nicht so gut. Und wir möchten das nicht. Wir haben sehr Instrumente, die wirklich Juwelen sind. Und wir möchten die nicht zerstören oder mit diesen Partikeln. Also was wir entschieden haben, ist, dass wir, wenn wir die Referenzbahn erreicht haben, bis dahin sind die Instrumente zum Teil geschützt. Aber wenn wir da ankommen, wechseln wir das Antriebssystem. Wir gehen von einem System, das zwei verschiedene chemische Materialien benutzt, um die Manövers zu machen, zum Monopropellantsystem, also mit einem einzigen chemischen Mittel. Und das ist besser für Kontamination. Das hat dann nicht diesen Effekt. Das ist viel sauberer.
Aber diese Steuerungseigenschaft bleibt erhalten.
Ja, aber nur für die Orientierung vom Satellit. Damit kann man nicht mehr große Bahnänderungen machen.
Nur um sich selber zu drehen.
Deswegen war diese Vorhersagung von der Bahn durch das Gravitationsfeld so wichtig. Nur so wissen wir ungefähr, wie sie rotieren wird, wie sie näher oder weiter weg vom Planeten bewegt. Nur so kann man das vorher sagen. Das können wir nicht mehr kompensieren.
Gehen wir mal noch ein bisschen zurück in der Zukunft zum eigentlichen Weg zum Merkur. Du hast ja schon angesprochen, der Merkur hat da seine Herausforderungen. Die große Anziehungskraft der Sonne, die Sonnenstrahlung an sich. Man darf da halt nicht von der Sonne eingefangen werden, etc. Das heißt, die eigentliche Trajektion, der Weg, den das Spacecraft nehmen muss, um da hinzukommen, ist schon relativ komplex. Was heißt das jetzt konkret? Womit wird gestartet?
Also wir starten mit einer Ariane 5 aus Kourou, Französische Guiana, und wir werden schon auf eine interplanetärische Bahn gestellt, also von Ariane 5. Das heißt, es ist eine Bahn um die Sonne, aber eine sehr erdähnliche Bahn. Und dann kommen wir vorbei nach ungefähr, also das ist nicht genau ein Jahr.
Was heißt erdähnlich, also parallel zur Erde?
Ja, also nicht nah an der Erde, aber ähnlich im Vergleich von der Erde.
Nur, dass es sich langsam nach innen reinschraubt.
Und das kommt zurück zur Erde. Und da haben wir unseren ersten Vorbeiflug. Wir benutzen die Erde, die Einziehungskraft der Erde, um uns weiter weg zu schieben. Also so ein Swing-By. Dann haben wir zwei Swing-Bys, Vorbeiflüge an Venus. Und dann fliegen wir immer noch um die Sonne herum, wie ein Planet selber. Und nach diesen zwei Swing-Bys an Venus kommen wir in den Abstand, der typisch ist für Merkur. Und da machen wir Vorbeiflüge, Swing-Bys, an Merkur selber, viermal. Und das bremst uns. Und in der Zwischenzeit benutzen wir unser elektrisches Propulsionssystem und weiterhin zu bremsen. Und es kommt ein Punkt, wo unsere relative Geschwindigkeit so niedrig ist, dass wir praktisch in diesen Bereich kommen, wo die Einzigenkraft von Merkur uns in seine eigenen Bahnen zieht. Das heißt Weak Stability Boundary, technisch auf Englisch. Das ist für die ESA auch das erste Mal, dass so eine Technik benutzt wird, um eine planetarische Insertion zu machen. Und das ist sehr gut, so eine Technik, weil die anderen Satelliten, die machen normalerweise eine riesenchemische Bremsmanöver, die Stunden dauern kann. Und wenn diese Manöver nicht funktioniert, dann das war es. Das ist das, was mit der japanischen Mission zu Venus vor kurzem passiert ist. Die haben diese Manöver nicht korrekt durchgeführt, oder es gab ein Problem. Das Manöver hat aufgehört in der Mitte, und dann erreicht man das Ziel nicht, und man weiß ja nicht, wo man landet. Das ist in diesem Fall sehr schwierig, die Mission zu retten. Manchmal gibt es eine Möglichkeit, doch zurückzukommen, das noch mal zu probieren, aber das ist wirklich keine Sicherheit. Wie hieß die Mission, die japanische?
Das haben wir dann in den Show Notes auf jeden Fall noch mit dabei. Das heißt, muss man mal zusammenfassen, BepiColombo fliegt los, wird von der Ariane schon so beschleunigt, dass es nicht nur die Erde verlässt, sondern quasi auch vor der Erde herfliegt. So, schneller als die Erde, die Sonne umrundet irgendwann nach wie vielen Jahren? Wie lange dauert das?
Der erste Vorbeiflug an der Erde ist innerhalb von dem ersten Flugjahr. Und dann gehen wir zu Venus zweimal. Das Gesamtflug von Start bis zur Initiation an Merkur dauert bis zu sechs Jahren und ein Viertel.
Ich wollte mir diesen Weg noch mal in Gedanken nachgehen. Man fliegt quasi so vor der Erde her, holt sie dann schnell ein. Wie muss man sich diesen Swing-By vorstellen? Relativ zur Sonne fliegt dann BepiColombo auf der Sonnenseite oder auf der Sonnenabgewandten Seite an der Erde vorbei? Das hängt vom Swing-By ab.
Die Geometrie kann sich sehr ändern. Das hängt davon ab.
Das steht noch gar nicht fest?
Doch, doch, das steht fest. In der Dokumentation ist die Geometrie genau beschrieben. Aber die ändert sich für jeden Swing-By abhängend von der Zeit. Kann mal so, mal so sein. Zum Beispiel an Venus gehen wir im Schatten von der Sonne für eine kurze Zeit beim Vorbeiflug. Manchmal hat man auch eine Interaktion vom Kontakt zur Erde. Weil man vom Satellit Richtung Erde aus gesehen, der vorbeifliegende Planet in der Mitte fliegt. Also das hängt da vom Swing-By ab. Aber ja, man fliegt vorbei, der Abstand ändert sich auch. Wir haben bestimmte Vorbeiflüge, die im 1000er Kilometer Range sind. Aber die an Merkur sind sehr nah. Die sind 200 oder 300 Kilometer weg vom Planet. Also das wird alles berechnet vorher.
Aber was ist jetzt der eigentliche Zweck dieser Swing-By? Geht es darum, Geschwindigkeit aufzunehmen? Geht es darum, näher an die Sonne heranzukommen?
Es hängt davon ab, manche holt man sich dann Geschwindigkeit. Man möchte schneller gehen. Die an Venus sind nicht so sehr, das geht dann darum, nicht so sehr um Geschwindigkeit, aber eher um Bahnänderung. Also Richtung der Bahn. Die Bahn kann man damit rotieren. An Merkur geht es darum, dass man bremst, dass man Geschwindigkeit verliert.
Aber im Prinzip ist die Strategie so, dass man sich in langsamen Spiralen nach innen... Es ist nicht so, wie man vielleicht auf den ersten Blick glauben würde, wo Merkur dahinten fliegt, da fliegen wir jetzt mal direkt hin. Dann hätte man so eine irre Speed drauf, dass man einfach oft den Merkur prallen würde oder dran vorbei.
Im Weltraum funktioniert das ja nicht so. Im Weltraum, wo nichts ist, ist die Mechanik nicht wie auf der Erde. Auf der Erde kann man sagen, ich mache eine Linie, aber im Weltraum fliegt jeder Objekt eher eine Ellipse oder eine Hyperbole. So eine Bahn. Man muss dann genau berechnen, was die Effekte von den verschiedensten Körpern sind und was für einen Effekt sie haben und wie die Bahn ändert. Dazu haben wir die elektrische Propulsion. Das heißt, es ist nicht wie bei Rosetta zum Beispiel, wo es nur chemische Propulsion gibt. Das ist dann wie ein Billardspiel. Man kommt vorbei an einen Körper, die Energie ändert sich und dadurch ändert sich die Bahn. Aber wenn man weiter weg ist von diesem Körper, ist der Einfluss kleiner und dann kann man die Bahn sehr genau vorhersagen oder berechnen, wie die weitergeht. Mit elektrischer Propulsion ändert man die Bahn kontinuierlich aber sehr wenig. Das heißt, man geht weg von diesen perfekten Ellipse zum Beispiel. Man kann die wirklich komplett steuern, Stück bei Stück, aber in sehr wenigen Stücken. Das ist noch etwas, was die ganze Berechnung kompliziert. Man muss das komplett numerisch integrieren, was die gesamte Bahn gebaut hat.
Heißt das, dass der chemische Antrieb in der ersten Phase vor allem zum Einsatz kommt für die großen Schritte?
Nein, der chemische Antrieb für BepiColombo ist nur für Navigation in der Nähe von den Planeten benutzt. Sonst fliegen wir eher eine ganz normale ballistische Bahn. Wir lassen den Satellit im Weltraum durch die Gravitation vom Sonnensystem weiterlaufen. Oder wir setzen das auf der richtigen Bahn. Es ist ja vorher gesagt, wir haben oft eine richtige Bahn. Wir korrigieren, dass es auf dieser Bahn ist. Aber wenn wir erst mal da sind, können wir das laufen lassen.
Wann setzt du diese Korrektur ein? Nachdem die Ariane das Playscraf abgesetzt hat? Dann korrigiert man noch mal ein bisschen?
Und nach den Swing-Bys, nach den Vorbeiflügen an den Planeten. Die sind manchmal nicht so genau, wie man das theoretisch berechnet hat. Man kann ja die Position des Satellits durch Daten von den Bodenstationen rekonstruieren. Und man korrigiert dann kurz nachher. Typischerweise machen wir solche Manövers mit chemischen Antrieb innerhalb von einem Monat vor dem Swing-By. Das wird den richtigen Swing-By-Punkt erreichen, so genau wie möglich. Und dann nachher, so ungefähr sieben Tage nachher, machen wir noch eine Korrektur. Es sei denn, wir nutzen den elektrischen Antrieb gleich. Denn dadurch kann man auch Korrekturen machen. Die dauern nur etwas länger.
Sind aber feiner.
Sie sind aber kleiner und feiner. Und es dauert länger, bis man dasselbe Delta-V hat.
Man verbraucht vor allem keinen Treibstoff, sondern nur die Sonnenpannele.
Das ist auch Treibstoff.
Ich dachte, das wäre nur über die Solarpannele.
Nein, da hat man auch einen neutralen Gas, der durch den Antrieb geht.
Man schraubt sich langsam Richtung Merkur. Je nach Bedarf, vor allem am Anfang, nach dem Absetzen. Und dann vermutlich auch nach den Swing-Balls, je nachdem, wie gut die gelungen sind. Das könnte ja theoretisch auch sein, dass man so super gezielt hat, dass es immer passt.
Also wir gehen davon aus, wenn man nur ballistisch geht, können Manövers sehr präzise sein. Das ist manchmal passiert, dass wir sagen, okay, bei Bedarf noch zwei, drei Tage vorher noch ein Manöver. Und das war nicht wirklich nötig, weil die Manöver sehr genau gewesen sind. Es hängt wirklich davon ab, wie präzise das gesamte Propulsionssystem im Flug ist. Also wie präzise er gebaut worden ist. Wir machen eine Charakterisation nach dem Start. Und dann kann es sein, dass er sehr genau ist. Aber mit elektrischer Propulsion, das wird ein bisschen schwieriger sein. Weil wir auch, wir möchten ja nicht die ganze Zeit Kontakt mit dem Satellit haben. Weil das kostet ja Geld und das kostet ja auch Arbeit für die Leute, die hier sind im Kontrollraum. Und deswegen haben wir gesagt, ok, wenn wir wissen, dass das gut funktioniert, dann werden wir nur einmal pro Woche Kontakt haben. Das machen wir auch mit anderen Satelliten, aber die sind ja relativ passiv, während das passiert. Und BepiColombo wird ja diesen Ion-Antrieb, also diese elektrische Propulsion, aktiv haben die ganze Zeit. Und wir sind ja nicht da für eine Woche. Also wir wissen, dass wir den Kontakt noch schaffen. Das ist kein Problem von der Genauigkeit, weil wir ja weg von der Erde sind. Das ist kein Problem. Aber es kann ja sein, dass die Performance von diesem Antrieb oder kleine Problemchen, die drin passieren sind, oder vielleicht muss er sich selber reconfigurieren oder egal was, dann ist es ziemlich möglich, dass wir dann, wenn wir den ausschalten, am Ankunft von so einem Swing bei, es ist sehr möglich, dass wir da noch ein bisschen korrigieren müssen. Im Fakt, wir gehen davon aus, dass es notwendig sein wird.
Wie stellt denn eigentlich so diese, also stellt der Merkur oder eine Merkur-Mission auch besondere Anforderungen an die Kommunikation? Ist das problematisch mit dem Spacecraft zu kommunizieren, wenn der sich so nah an der Sonne befindet? Ist da der Sonnenwind, der ja bekannt ist dafür, die Telekommunikation auch beeinflussen zu können? Ist das nochmal eine spezielle Herausforderung oder ist das ein beherrschtes Problem?
Das ist beherrscht, aber das ist auch, muss gut bedacht werden. Wir kommunizieren ja mit einer Radiofrequenz, das ist das X-Band für Befehle, also Kommandos und Telemetrie, also die Daten, die runterkommen. Wir wissen von den anderen Missionen, dass diese Radiofrequenz, wenn das nah an der Sonne ist, das wird ja degradiert, das wird nicht mehr so gut und es gibt eine Winkeldistanz, wo man nicht mehr kommunizieren kann. Wir planen immer und sagen, wenn der Winkel zwischen, vom Satellit aus gesehen, zwischen Sonne und Erde weniger als 3 Grad ist, dann gehen wir davon aus, dass nichts durchgeht.
Also wenn Sonne und Erde aus Sicht des Satelliten zu nah beieinander stehen.
Weil der Signal vom Satellit zur Erde muss ja in diesem Fall relativ nah an der Sonne vorbei. Und wir wissen von den Erfahrungen von den anderen Missionen, Rosetta, Mars Express, Venus Express, wo diese Bedingungen regelmäßig vorbeipassieren. Wir haben genaue Messungen gemacht und wir wissen, dass unter drei Grad, das ist ein bisschen heikel. Da geht man lieber davon aus, dass nichts geht. Man plant das und dann ist es okay. Innerhalb von fünf Grad, so von fünf Grad bis drei Grad, wir wissen, dass es könnte gehen, aber man ist nicht so sicher. Man sagt, da lieber keine Manöver zum Beispiel machen, keine kritische Operation. Man plant so, dass man da keine kritische Operation braucht. Außerhalb geht es normalerweise, aber von fünf bis zehn Grad gibt es auch so einen Effekt eigentlich. Bei den anderen Missionen ist man relativ weg aus diesem Bereich, weil die weg sind von Planeten, die weiter weg sind. Man muss sich da nicht so viele Sorgen machen, aber für BepiColombo werden wir sehr oft in diesem Bereich sein. Und wir denken, dass das okay ist, weil von unserer Erfahrung ist das normalerweise in Ordnung, aber wir werden das noch genau karakterieren.
Aber auch das sind sozusagen Faktoren, die man in die Missionsplanung gleich mit einrechnen muss, dass man nicht sagt, jetzt machen wir ein Manöver, blöd, jetzt sind wir aber leider zu nah an der Sonne dran, das geht dann nicht.
Das geht z.B. in dieser ganzen Arbeit, wir nennen das Mission-Analysis, das sind die Leute, die diese ganzen Bahnberechnungen machen. Das ist ein Expertbereich der ESA, das wird auch hier in Darmstadt gemacht. Und diese Kollegen, wir besprechen ja diese Constraints zusammen. Wir sagen ja, hier könnt ihr eigentlich keinen Swing-By haben, weil in dieser Geometrie von diesem Swing-By sind wir zu nah an der Sonne von dem Kommunikationswinkel aus gesehen. Und das kann nicht gehen, weil der Signal, den wir brauchen, um die Navigation zu machen, wird nicht gut genug sein. Und dann kann man nicht garantieren, dass wir die Navigation bis zu diesem Punkt erreichen können. Das wird in der Bahnberechnung, in der Bahnplanung von Anfang an berücksichtigt. Das Ganze ist auch sehr wichtig.
BepiColombo muss sich ja, du hast ja vorhin schon gesagt, es gibt dieses Gitterschutzschild, was die Sonnenstrahlung abhält, damit sich alles nicht zu sehr aufheizt. Die Ausrichtung, macht das der BepiColombo selbst?
Die Orientierung?
Ja, er beobachtet selber auch immer die Sterne und weiß, wo er ist.
Er weiß, wo er ist, von Star Trekker. Wir nehmen den, und die Orientierung wird von Boden aus programmiert. Wir schicken Kommandos, wo wir sagen, wie der Orientierungsprofil auszusehen hat. Und dann macht er das selber. Wir machen auch dasselbe im Fall von einem Problem, wie der Satellit sich reconfigurieren und in einen sogenannten Safe Mode gehen. Die Orientierung für diesen Safe Mode wird auch von Boden aus programmiert. Aber dann macht er alles selber. Der Satellit hat diese Multi-Layer-Insulation, also diese Thermal-Covers an der Seite. Und um den Heat, also der Satellit wird ja heiß von drinnen, weil die ganzen Elemente, wenn die funktionieren, die strahlen auch Wärme ab. Und diese ganze Wärme muss auch abgeleitet werden. Und es gibt dafür eine ganze Seite vom Satellit, die einen Radiator hat, das lässt dann diese Wärme raus. Und dieser Radiator ist auch eine neue technologische Entwicklung für BepiColombo, das wurde neu entwickelt und ist neu gebaut für die Mission. Es ist wirklich optimiert, sodass die Strahlung zurück von der Merkur-Oberfläche auch nicht ins Satellit reinkommt. Der Satellit ist ja immer zwischen Sonne und Merkur. Merkur strahlt auch Wärme ab, sehr viel. Man sagt, an Merkur selber hat man zehn Solarkonstanz, also diese Energie von der Sonne, von der Sonne selber und vier von der Merkur-Oberfläche. Man ist wirklich in Sandwich zwischen diesen zwei wahnsinnigen Wärmequellen. Dabei muss der Satellit selber eine Balanztemperatur haben, sonst kann die Elektronik nicht mehr funktionieren. Elektronik ist in Büchern ungefähr Raumtemperatur, so 20 Grad ist gut. Bei BepiColombo werden wir uns wahrscheinlich näher an 40, 50 Grad bewegen, weil das einfach auch anders nicht möglich ist. Aber das heisst, diese ganze Wärme muss wirklich weg vom Satellit, sonst kann das nicht funktionieren.
Wir machen das so. Das ist ganz schön happig. Wenn man sieht, dass der Merkur sich schon zu 450 Grad aufheizt, dann ist natürlich auch die Sonnenstrahlung eine ziemliche Herausforderung. Ich frage mich jetzt, was der technische Unterschied ist zwischen den Radiatoren von BepiColombo und den, wie sie jetzt zum Beispiel auf der ISS eingesetzt werden, weil das Problem entstandene Wärme, gerade von den ganzen Experimenten und sonstigen Lebenserhaltungssystemen, die ja auch permanent Wärme erzeugen, die abzuleiten, das ist ja da auch ein Teil davon. Die großen Strukturen sind nicht nur Solarpanele, sondern eben auch die Radiatoren.
Die meisten Satelliten, also Rosetta und Mars Express und Venus Express, haben auch Radiatoren. Aber in dem Fall von BepiColombo ist das wirklich die Form von den Strukturen, die diese Wärme ableiten. Also er hat eine ganz gewisse Form, die wirklich optimiert ist, dass die Rückstrahlung von Merkur wegreflektiert wird und nicht reinkommt. Und das ist eine Besonderheit.
Also sozusagen so Reflektor und Radiator in einem?
In einem, optimiert für diese Mission.
Vielleicht können wir nochmal ein bisschen genauer auf die Aktivität von BepiColombo eingehen, wenn wir dann bei Merkur angekommen sind. Also jetzt haben wir diese 6 Jahre, 6,5 Jahre Anflugsphase durch. Dann wird gebremst. So lange gebremst, bis der Merkur sagt, hier, du bleibst jetzt hier. Dann trennen sich die beiden Satelliten. Wie heißen diese beiden Satelliten?
Also der Europäische heißt MPO, Mercury Planetary Orbiter, und der Japanische heißt MMO, Mercury Magnetospheric Orbiter.
Okay, also MPO und MMO, alles klar. Der MPO hat jetzt mehr Instrumente als der MMO.
Ja, ungefähr, also doppelt. Und was wir machen, wenn wir angekommen sind, ist, dass wir erstmal die Instrumente testen. Die sind ja zum ersten Mal in ihren Ziel umgebungen. Die waren früher schon getestet, dass die den Start überlebt haben. Das machen wir direkt nach dem Start, für die ersten drei Monate ungefähr. Aber es gibt viele Funktionen, die man da nicht testen kann. Einfach weil die meisten Instrumente sind auf der Seite von MPO, die auf dem Antriebsmodul zeigt. Einfach der Stack ist so aufgebaut. Das heißt, man kann nichts aufnehmen mit diesen Instrumente. Der andere Modul muss erstmal weg. Dann kann man zum ersten Mal nach sechs Jahren direkt im Weltall gucken. Das ist sehr wichtig. Man muss da Kalibration machen. Das ist die Commissioning Phase. Die wird an Merkur. Wir planen ungefähr einen Monat, also vier Wochen ungefähr. Die Instrumente zum ersten Mal einzeln. Dann machen wir auch Messungen alle zusammen, um zu sehen, ob die miteinander interferieren oder nicht. Wie das aussieht, wenn das gesamte Instrumentpaket zusammen operiert. Das muss man auch ein bisschen charakterisieren. Wenn das getan ist, fangen wir mit der wissenschaftlichen Mission an. Wir haben ein Zentrum, der für Instrumentenoperationen verantwortlich ist. Die sind in ESAQ, das ist ein Zentrum der ESA in Spanien, in Villafranca. Die sind dafür verantwortlich, aufzunehmen und zu sammeln, was die Instrumente machen wollen. Die werden alle in Richtung Merkur-Oberfläche gucken. Aber es gibt manchmal interessante Punkte, wo man den Satelliten umorientieren muss. Man muss sich hier einigen, wann man das tut, und welche Instrumente für solche Operationen angeschaltet sind. Manche Instrumente brauchen auch regelmäßig Kalibration. Sie müssen überhaupt karakterisieren, was sie sehen. An bestimmte Quellen, die gut verstanden sind. Das heißt, wir müssen diese Kalibrationsoperation auch regelmäßig einbauen in der Planung. Das macht auch das Zentrum in ESAK. Die bauen dann einen Plan von wissenschaftlicher Operation. Die stellen sicher, dass dieser Plan kompatibel ist mit den Ressourcen vom Satelliten, also Energie und Daten. Dass alle Daten, die gesammelt werden, auch runtergeschickt werden können. Das wäre ja schade, wenn wir nicht genug Bandwidth-Platz hätten auf dem Link. Das wird alles vorher geplant. Dann kommen diese Instruktionen oder diese Request zu uns in Darmstadt. Wir machen daraus eine Gesamt-Kommando-Timeline. Wir stellen dazu die Kommandos vom Satelliten selbst, von der Plattform. Dann kommen wir mit einer gesamt-konsistenten Gruppe von Telekommandos, die man dann hochschickt zum Satellit. Die wissenschaftliche Mission wird ein Jahr dauern, mit der Möglichkeit, das zu erweitern. Der Satellit wird konzipiert für eine weitere Erweiterung von der Mission, von einem anderen Jahr. Dann sehen wir, wo wir sind. Wenn der Satellit immer noch in guter Verfassung. Befindet, dann machen wir weiter.
Was sind denn die Einflüsse, worunter könnte er vor allem leiden? Die Sonnennähe, die Hitze?
Die Hitze ist schon ein Riesenfaktor. Wir wissen, dass die sehr harsche Umgebung von Hitze und Radiation von der Sonne, also die Sonnenpartikel, das hat schon einen Effekt auf die Materialien, aus denen der Satellit gebaut ist. Das spielt eine große Rolle. Wir bauen immer mit Margin, aber wir haben noch keinen Satellit an der Nähe von Merkur gehabt. Wir wissen ja nicht, wie schnell, ob das sich degradiert, so wie wir jetzt denken.
Aber Messenger dürfte ja gerade genau das gleiche Problem haben.
Ja, da kann man auch schon mal was lernen davon. Das scheint bei Messenger keine bösen Überraschungen gegeben zu haben.
Und ist auch schon länger als ein Jahr im Betrieb. Was sind da so die Erwartungen, wie lange Messenger noch so durchhält?
Das weiß ich nicht genau. Das ist das Hauptproblem, ich denke die Degradation. Dann haben wir auch das Problem von dem Antrieb, also die Orientierung vom Satellit ist ja mit Reaction Wheels, also das sind diese große Räder, wo die Orientierung kompensiert wird. Das ist das, was der Satellit orientiert. Aber die sammeln ja diese Energie und manchmal müssen sie dekompensiert werden. Das wird mit chemischen Antrieb gemacht. Und auch für die Safe-Modes, wenn der Satellit ein Problem hat, dann benutzt man auch diesen chemischen Antrieb um in den sicheren Mode zu gehen. Und irgendwann ist da nichts mehr. Und dann ist es over.
Aber der Antrieb muss jetzt nicht genutzt werden, um den MPO in seiner Bahn zu halten. Also wenn der einmal eingeschossen ist. Bei der Erde hat man ja den Kampf gegen die Atmosphäre, den gibt es bei Merkur so nicht. Oder diese Partikel, die ausgehen.
Das ist der Effekt von Sonnenwind. Diese Effekte von Sonnenwind drücken ja gegen die Satellit-Oberfläche. Das ist eine nicht so starke Kraft, aber trotzdem.
Das ist kontinuierlich.
Wenn wir sagen, du Satellit, schau mal auf die Oberfläche von Merkur, es gibt diese gegenseitigen Effekte, die den Satellit versuchen zu drehen. Der kompensiert selber bis zu dem Punkt, wo diese Räder an ihren Limit angehen. Die müssen dann dekompensiert werden.
Also diese Räder sind sozusagen Fliehkräfte, einfach rotierende Scheiben.
Die diese Energie dann aufnehmen.
Und in so eine Drehbewegung dann umsetzen. So ähnlich macht die ISS das, glaube ich, auch anstellen.
Das ist eine klassische Technik. Wir haben das selbe mit Rosetta Mass Express.
Okay, verstehe. Ja, das bringt mich jetzt nochmal zu den Instrumenten selber. Das haben wir ja schon so ein bisschen angedeutet, aber ich glaube, das ist auch nochmal ganz interessant, einfach zu schauen, womit wird denn jetzt eigentlich beobachtet. Also der Flug ist abgeschlossen, alles ist super gelaufen, keine Probleme. Ganz viel Treibstoff gespart, ich kann es nur wünschen. Was bringt jetzt BepiColombo an Beobachtungsgerät mit, was jetzt auch so vorher noch nicht da war?
Also ich glaube, dass das eine, was nicht so, also bei Merkur sowieso, aber auch bei den anderen Planeten, wir haben einen Laser-Altimeter an Bord, das ist ziemlich wichtig. Also ich bin nicht sicher, ob der Messenger auch eins hat, aber wir tragen eins da. Und ansonsten sind die üblichen Instrumente aber optimiert für das, was man an Merkur erwartet. Also wir haben Kameras in verschiedenen Licht-Bereichen, wir haben Spektrometer, wir haben ein Instrument, das sich auf diese Partikel, dieses dynamisches Prozess von Sputtering spezialisiert hat, also das ermäßt, welche Partikel raus von der Oberfläche von Merkur genommen werden. Wir haben einen Gamma-Ray-Spektrometer und wir haben auch ein Instrument, das Radio-Science macht, also der Machtwissenschaft mit Radiosignalen in verschiedene Radio-Frequenzen.
Also er sendet Frequenzen zur Oberfläche?
Nicht zur Oberfläche, er nutzt den Link zur Erde, der ja in der Nähe von Merkur passiert, um eine sehr extrem genau Orbital Determination, also Bandberechnung, macht, aber in einer Genauigkeit, die viel besser ist, also mehrere Order of Magnitudes besser ist als die, die wir für Operations brauchen und das wird ja numerisch integriert während der gesamten Mission, sodass man dann ein sehr genaues Modell von Merkur selber, von Gravitationsfeld erreicht.
Das ist sozusagen die Methode, mit der das Gravitationsfeld dann auch ausgemessen wird, indem man einfach die eigene Bahn auswertet, so ist das ja auch klassisch gemacht worden. Da hatten wir ja in Raumzeit 40, wo es um Gottsche ging, in das interessiert wurden die Unterschiede der verschiedenen Messtechniken bis hin zu Gottsche auch nochmal vorgestellt. Ich habe gerade mal nachgeschaut, also Messenger hat auch ein Laser-Altimeter mit an Bord. Diese Höhenmessung ist natürlich extrem wichtig, um einfach mal auch eine detaillierte Kartierung zu machen. Abgesehen von der optischen Kartierung ist ja auch immer die Höhe eben wichtig, auch um das dann nochmal ins Verhältnis zu setzen zu der Gravitationsmessung, weil das lässt ja dann vermutlich auch Schlüsse zu auf die innere Beschaffenheit von Merkur.
Ja, absolut. Ich denke auch, ich habe von meinen wissenschaftlichen Kollegen, ich bin ja keine Wissenschaftlerin selber, gehört, dass Vulkanismus ist auch eine Frage. Also die Rolle von Vulkanismus auf Merkur, das war am Anfang überhaupt nicht, es wurde nicht damit berechnet, dass Vulkanismus unbedingt eine große Rolle gespielt hat. Aber man ist jetzt der Meinung, dass es doch eine Rolle gespielt hat oder vielleicht noch spielt, wer weiß.
Bei der Ausgestaltung des Planeten selber.
Also da kommt Messenger mit sehr interessanten Ergebnissen, auch was Strukturen an der Oberfläche angeht. Also die stellen wirklich sehr viele Fragen.
BepiColombo heißt?
Also das heißt BepiColombo nach dem italienischen Wissenschaftler Giuseppe Colombo. Er ist der, der eigentlich der NASA empfohlen hat für Mariner 10, eine Bahn um die Sonne zu fliegen, sodass man da mehrere Vorbeiflüge an Merkur haben kann. Also er ist sehr mit Bahnentwicklung beschäftigt.
Also er hat quasi dieses Prinzip der Annäherung an Merkur überhaupt erst aufgewacht.
Genau, er ist wirklich ein von den Pionieren für sowas.
Das ist ja insofern, finde ich das jetzt sehr interessant. Normalerweise fliegen die ganzen Größen der letzten Jahrhunderte, so Galileo, etc. Auch bei Colombo denkt man vielleicht erst mal an Colombo. Aber hier handelt es sich um jemanden, der 1920 geboren wurde und erst 1984 verstorben ist.
Ja, aber er hat wirklich sehr viel beigetragen zu Merkur-Missionen. Er ist wirklich, ich glaube, der, der diese Ideen gehabt hat, wie man überhaupt da, ich habe ja erwähnt am Anfang, zu Merkur zu gehen, ist interessant wissenschaftlich, aber das ist auch ein technisches Challenge. Und diese Bahnentwicklung, dieses Bahndesign, um überhaupt da hinzukommen, innerhalb von einem Budget, was machbar ist, weil wenn man unendliche Energie mittragen kann, kann man alles machen, aber das ist ja nicht der Fall. Also die Rakete ist begrenzt und der Satellit ist begrenzt. BepiColombo kämpft ja auch für das Gewicht, das es mitnehmen kann. Jede Mission tut es, aber bei Bepis ist das auch noch ein heißes Thema. Und ich denke, er ist wirklich ein von den Väter von diesem Konzept.
Bepi, muss man dazu sagen, ist ein Spitzname. An sich heißt er Giuseppe. Aber ich finde es trotzdem interessant, dass man jetzt auch mal zumindest ins letzte Jahrhundert zurückgreift und langsam mal die Pioniere der modernen Raumfahrt würdigt und nicht immer nur die ganzen Mathematiker und sonstigen Grundlagenforscher der letzten Jahrhunderte. Wobei, ich glaube, man hat da auch alle durch langsam. Also es ist wahrscheinlich auch einfach keiner mehr übrig, nachdem man irgendwas benennen kann. Dein Team, wie groß ist das? Wie viele Leute beschäftigen sich jetzt quasi mit dieser Mission? Wie viele Leute haben sich das ausgedacht? Wie viele Leute werden dann das Ganze steuern?
Man muss ein bisschen unterscheiden. Solche Projekte beschäftigen ja wirklich eine sehr große Gemeinschaft in Europa und in der Welt. Also so ein Projekt ist, die Projektleitung ist eigentlich in Estek. Das ist auch ein Zentrum der ESA, in der Niederlande. Da wird die Gesamtprojektleitung, also das heißt, da werden die Verträge mit Industrie gemanagt und die Entwicklung vom Satellit wird verfolgt.
Also das ist sozusagen die eigentliche Zentrale, die dann auch die ganze wissenschaftliche Arbeit, die da dranhängt, mit integriert.
Ja, die machen auch die Schnittstelle zu der wissenschaftlichen Gemeinschaft, also für den Bau von den Instrumenten und für die Definition und Implementation von den Schnittstellen zwischen Instrumenten und Satelliten. Das ist wirklich eine komplexe Struktur mit vielen Kollegen, die sich damit beschäftigen. Dann gibt es in der Industrie und in der wissenschaftlichen Gemeinschaft at large, gibt es sehr viele Kollegen, die damit beschäftigt sind. Ich habe keine Zahlen, aber das sind wirklich sehr große Gruppen, weil wir brauchen sehr viele Spezialisten in verschiedenen Disziplinen, um das zu machen. Das reine Bauen von dem Satellit braucht noch etwas. Es gibt extrem viele Verträge, die dann weitergegeben werden, um das Ganze zu bauen und ins Leben zu rufen. Hier in Darmstadt machen wir den Betrieb. Das heißt, wir haben eine Gruppe, die sich mit Mission Analys verfasst. Das sind die Leute, die diese Bahnberechnungen machen. Wir haben ja davon gesprochen. In Betrieb selber gibt es mein Team, also die Flugkontrollteam. Wir werden sieben Ingenieure sein und vier Techniker im Team selber. Wir werden da unterstützt von einem Team, der die Flugdynamik macht. Die ganzen Bahnänderungen, Orientierung vom Satellit, Betrieb von den AUCS-Elementen, alles was mit Satellitendynamik hat, also Orientierung, Attitude und Bahnänderung, Propulsion, wird von diesem Team gemacht. Die berechnen das Ganze, die machen das Monitoring von diesen Elementen, die machen die Kalibrationen und die geben uns dann die Parameter für die eigentlichen Befehle, die gebraucht werden. Und mein Team tut das in diesem gesamten Timeline und ist dafür verantwortlich, dass die Kommando, die wir von draußen bekommen haben, richtig ins Bits and Bytes konvertiert werden, dass das gesamte Paket Sinn macht, dass da keine Fehler runtergelaufen sind, dass das Ganze mit den Ressourcen vom Satellit passt, dass die Energie, die wir dadurch benutzen, nicht höher ist, als das, was der Satellit bringen kann. Dass die Daten in Zeit, wo wir sie brauchen, zurückkommen, etc. Das ist dann die Hauptverantwortlichkeit von meinem Team. Aber das ist eine riesige Teamarbeit. Da kann man nicht sagen, dass das Ganze von drei Personen gemacht wird. Das sind sehr viele Spezialisten.
Klar ist es auch gut, das so in der Größe vorzustellen. Konkret ist auch das Team, das den Betrieb macht, um einfach mal ein Gefühl dafür zu bekommen, wie viele Leute sind jetzt nötig.
Wie gesagt, sieben. Weil wir diese Struktur haben mit der Flugdynamik in einem anderen organisatorischen Bereich innerhalb von der ESOC, die werden nicht dazu berechnet, aber die sind Teil des Flugkontrollteams. Ohne diese Gruppe könnten wir den Betrieb überhaupt nicht machen. Solche Satelliten sind so kompliziert von der Dynamik, von dem Point von Dynamik. Es gibt andere Familien von Satelliten, wo man da nicht so viel machen muss. Aber ein interplanetärischer Satellit muss genau an dem Punkt sein, wo man den braucht, sodass die Swing-Bikes laufen, sodass die Insertion funktioniert, sodass man nur kommunizieren kann mit dem. Wenn der zu weit weg ist oder man nicht richtig berechnet hat, wo er sich in einer Woche befinden muss, hat man keinen Kontakt. Man weiß nicht, wo er ist. Das wird nicht direkt von meinem Team gemacht, sondern von diesen Kollegen, die Flugdynamiker. Deswegen sage ich immer, wir arbeiten wirklich zusammen. In anderen Strukturen, wie bei der NASA, sind wir ein einziges Team, das sich wahrscheinlich auch Flugleitung nennt. Bei uns sind das zwei getrennte Strukturen, aber wir arbeiten wie eine, weil wir beide Disziplinen brauchen.
Der Start ist im August 2015, jetzt haben wir 2012. Jetzt könnte man denken, naja, es ist ja noch drei Jahre hin. Aber in gewisser Hinsicht hat für euch schon die heiße Phase begonnen.
Eigentlich war der Start vor ein paar Monaten, immer noch Juli 2014. Wir haben jetzt ein Jahr gewonnen, aber wir waren vorbereitet, den Start in zwei Jahren zu machen. Das heißt, wir haben das gesamte Bodensegment, die gesamte Bodensegmentelemente sind schon in Entwicklung. Dieses Jahr fangen wir damit an, diese Elemente zu bekommen. Wir müssen die akzeptieren, also testen, integrieren.
Also Bodensegmentelemente heißt, was jetzt hier auf der Erde die Kommunikation mit BepiColombo aufbeterhält.
Die Bodenstationen existieren ja schon, aber das Kontrollsystem, das ist das Gehirn von dem Gesamtsystem. Das ist das System, das die Daten interpretiert, die zurückkommen, die Telemetrie und die Befehle in Bits und Bytes konvertiert und dann die weiter schickt zu den Bodenstationen. Das ist ein komplexes System, das einfach funktionieren muss.
Und da ist man dann wiederum zusammen mit den Leuten von S-Trek?
Von S-Trek und wir haben Kontraktoren hier in Darmstadt, die das mit uns machen. Wir haben Kontraktoren für das Mission Control System, also das Kontrollsystem, den Simulator, mit dem wir trainieren werden. Und wir haben auch ein Planning-System, ein System, der uns hilft, diese Timeline von Befehlen zu bauen und zu integrieren, zu checken. Das ist auch ein sehr komplexes System und das wird jetzt entwickelt für uns. Und die Systeme kommen langsam rein. Dieses Jahr ist das Jahr der Anfang von Tests. Wir haben ja im Juni unseren ersten Test mit dem Satelliten selber. Wir machen so einen Test, dass unsere Systeme die Kommandos korrekt bauen und dass wir die Telemetrie interpretieren können. Wir haben vor einem Monat ungefähr die ersten Daten von Satelliten überhaupt hier bekommen. Das motiviert uns selbst und das ist viel Arbeit.
In dem Zusammenhang auch noch mal ein Verweis auf zwei alte Raumzeitsendungen. Das mache ich ja mal gerne, weil es sich immer so schön ergänzt. Raumzeit 28 hat sich konkret mit dem S-Trek-Bodenstationsnetzwerk auseinandergesetzt. Da kommt auch noch mal sehr schön zur Sprache, wie eben diese Zusammenarbeit zwischen den eigentlichen Missionsplanern und eben dem Bodensegment konkret abläuft. Und was ja hier auch generell eine große Rolle spielt, eben diese komplexe Missionsplanung. Das war schon die zweite Ausgabe hier auch vom ESA und Markus Landgraf, wo das mehr am Beispiel vom Mars Express beleuchtet wurde, aber am Ende, zwingbar etc., diese ganzen Thematiken, das kommt natürlich hier genauso zur Sprache und spielt hier genauso eine Rolle, wie eben bei den anderen Missionen auch. Wenn es dann zum Start kommt, inwiefern müssen wir euch dann noch mit Kuru auseinandersetzen, oder ist das alles erstmal gar nicht das Thema?
Also kurz vor dem Start, ungefähr 4 Monate vor, 3-4 Monaten vor dem Start, fangen wir an mit sogenannten Simulationen. Also das ist, man muss sich das vorstellen, ich finde das immer so spannend. Das ist dann, wo alle Teams, die beim Start aktiv sind, zusammenkommen und trainiert werden, und dann zu eins werden. Also die Leute von Industrie kommen, das Projekt aus ESDEC. Wir sind hier sowieso, also die Gesamtgruppe, die ESOC, BepiColombo-spezifische Teams, aber auch die Unterstützungskollegen, die Multimissionen-Support machen, aber in dem Fall BepiColombo unterstützen müssen. Die kommen erstmal alle zusammen, jeder aus seiner eigenen Welt und Erfahrung und werden zu einem Team trainiert. Während dieser Zeit wird der Satellit in Kourou für den Start vorbereitet. Es gibt einen Teil von Projektkollegen, die in Kourou sind und das mitmachen. Industrie ist auch eher in Kourou. Wir haben noch einen Test an der Stelle, einen Schnittstellentest, so einen SVT, wir nennen das System Validischen Test, mit dem Satellit innerhalb von dieser letzten Phase. Aber sonst haben wir relativ wenig mit den Aktivitäten in Kourou zu tun, weil wir unsere eigene Post-Start, Post-Launch-Aktivitäten vorbereiten. Wir machen aber eine oder zwei Simulationen von sogenannten Countdown. Countdown ist eine Simulation, die die letzten Aktivitäten vor dem Start in Kourou, die noch zur Pre-Launch-Phase gehören, und die ersten Aktivitäten von Post-Launch-Zeiten, die eigentliche Übernahme von uns, alles in einer eigenen Simulation probiert werden, getestet werden.
Inklusive aller möglichen Fehler, die man...
Ja, normalerweise macht man ein Szenario ohne Fehler und dann ein paar vielleicht mit Fehler. Aber der mit Kourou, das ist eine Simulation, weil normalerweise die Simulationen mit Fehler, unser Simulation-Officer sagt einfach, er sei Kourou. Und wir lassen die Kollegen in Kourou nicht mitspielen, weil das sehr komplex zu organisieren ist und die haben bessere Sachen zu tun. Also das machen wir einfach hier simuliert. Aber einmal machen wir das mit denen da. Und schauen, dass alles reibungslos läuft, dass die Prozeduren, die die haben, die wir hier haben, gut miteinander funktionieren. Das muss man machen. Und dann sind wir in den Start, sitzen wir hier im Kontrollraum. Wir warten, dass das Satellit getrennt wird und dass wir Daten bekommen. Und dass wir die Kontrolle übernehmen können. Und die Kollegen in Kourou übersehen den Start. Und dann, nach dem Start, ist ihre eigentliche Aufgabe vorbei.
Und dann gibt es diesen magischen Moment, wo man auf das erste Signal wartet. Dann fällt der größte Stein vom Herzen.
Ja, denn da fängt es an. Das fängt alles da an. Das ist sehr, sehr spannend, dieser Moment. Ich habe es mit Rosetta erlebt. Ich werde mich mein Leben lang erinnern. Man hat so viel getan bis dahin. Und man wundert sich ein bisschen auch, ob das alles klappen wird. Das gibt eine gewisse Emotion und Tension auch. Und dann kommen die Daten. Und alles, worauf man sich so stark und intensiv vorbereitet hat, das wird zur Realität. Das fängt endlich an. Wobei es schon vor fünf Jahren oder zehn Jahren angefangen hat. Das ist ein sehr interessanter Moment. Man muss denken, es gibt viele Kollegen, die beim Start für den das Ende des Projekts sind. Es gibt so eine Übernahme ein bisschen. Ein Handshake zwischen Gruppen. Diese große Gemeinschaft trifft zusammen für den Start. Die manchen werden sich andere Aufgaben wenden. Für uns wird es dann zur Hauptaufgabe. Das ist ein sehr interessantes Moment.
Die eine Verschiebung, die es jetzt schon gab, war dann um ein Jahr. Ist das der Zyklus? Sollte es jetzt wieder eine Verzögerung geben, aus welchen Gründen auch immer? Könnte man dann wirklich im jeden weiteren Jahr dasselbe Spiel machen? Es hängt ja extrem davon ab, wie Venus, Merkur und Erde eben so zueinander stehen.
Bisher haben wir das Glück gehabt, dass wir fast jedes Jahr eine Option gefunden haben. So ungefähr im Sommer. Ich weiß nicht, ob das so sein sollte. Das könnten meine Mission-Analysiskollegen besser erklären. Oder ob das Zufall ist. Aber im Moment war es immer möglich. Aber wir haben schon gesehen, von Studien, die vorher gemacht worden sind, es kostet nicht immer dasselbe. Also das propellende Budget, das man dafür haben kann. Man kann vielleicht eine Kombination finden. Aber die Hauptfrage jetzt wird sein, wie viel Treibstoff es braucht, weil der Satellit jetzt gebaut wird. Und man kann den Treibstoff nicht plötzlich verdoppeln. Also im Moment läuft es ziemlich gut. Wir haben jetzt einen Start im August 2015 gefunden, was in Ordnung ist. Und wir haben einen Backup eigentlich in 2016.
Mit ähnlichen Anforderungen.
Ja, was gut passt, was im Budget ist. Wir werden wahrscheinlich demnächst anfangen, genauer zu gucken, was dann nachher passiert. Und mal schauen. Aber man kann nicht sagen, dass man jedes Jahr sicher eine Option findet.
Und es ist jetzt auch nicht so, dass man einfach in den Kalender gucken kann, wann passt das als nächstes Mal. Man muss ja im Prinzip die komplette Konzeption, diese ganze Annäherung etc. mit zwingbares etc. in Abhängigkeit der Konstellation der Planetenwiese sich dann eben ergibt. Das ist vorher sagbar, aber man muss so ein bisschen die Nadel im Heuhaufen suchen.
Das ist unsere Aufgabe. Aber es ist besonders kompliziert, glaube ich, für BepiColombo, weil das Ganze jedes Mal nummerlich integriert sein muss. Von Start bis zur Ankunft, 6,3 Jahre. Das muss es geben, weil diese elektrische Propulsion-Effekt, man kann nicht sagen, einfach eine Linie auf Papier ziehen und sagen, wir machen jetzt elektrische Propulsion und das Effekt in 6 Monaten ist das. Das geht nicht so. Das dauert sehr lange. Manchmal gibt das Software kein Ergebnis. Da muss man noch gucken, was das Problem genau da ist. Ob man das ein bisschen tunen kann oder ob man wirklich auf eine ganz andere Option gehen muss. Das ist eine sehr besondere Arbeit unserer Mission Analysis-Kollegen. Sehr wichtig und gar nicht einfach.
Ja, da kann ich ja nur viel Glück wünschen. Wenn dann der Start geklappt hat, gehen wir mal jetzt von 2015 aus, dann dürfte es wahrscheinlich eine mehrmonatige, sehr intensive Phase geben, wo man sich jetzt erstmal um die Inbetriebnahme, die möglichen Tests, quasi so eine Pre-Commission-Face darauf konzentriert. Aber irgendwann ist ja dann die Trajektion auch eingeleitet, dann muss man erstmal wieder ein Jahr warten, bis eigentlich was Spannendes passiert, oder?
Ja, also das ist bei BepiColombo ein bisschen anders. Also es stimmt, dass die Inbetriebnahme-Fase, die Commissioning, also drei Monate, und das wird sehr intensiv, aber dann müssen wir auch die Inbetriebsnahme von elektrischem Propulsionsystem machen und das kann man nicht unbedingt ganz, also man macht das schon innerhalb von diesen drei Monaten, muss ja auch, weil der dann direkt eingesetzt wird sonst, also man muss ja das vorher testen, aber wenn man diesen Test in ein paar Wochen gemacht hat, das heißt noch nicht lange, dass man den Satellit alleine lassen kann. Also das heißt, wir werden wahrscheinlich bis zum Vorbeiflug an der Erde, was ungefähr ein Jahr später, ich habe die genauen Daten nicht im Kopf, aber ungefähr innerhalb von einem Jahr später ist, wir werden da ziemlich intensiv noch nach dem Satellit gucken. Man weiß auch nicht, was man in dem Commissioning-Face findet, manchmal gibt es da ein bisschen Sachen, die man regeln möchte, sodass die dann geglättet sind. Das kann heißen, vielleicht ein Software Patch installieren oder nochmal einen Test machen, solche Sachen. Ich gehe davon aus, dass das erste Jahr ziemlich intensiv sein wird. In den Phasen, in denen wir keine elektrische Propulsion haben, ist das relativ ruhig, weil da der Satellit fliegt ja seine Bahn ballistisch. Wir müssen ja kommunizieren, aber wir können das vorher programmieren. Die Instrumente werden nicht benutzt, also das ist relativ ruhig. Wenn elektrische Propulsion benutzt wird, müssen wir uns erstmal vergewissern, dass es in Ordnung ist.
Also später, wenn es um die Venus geht, kann es schon mal sein, dass man ein halbes Jahr keinen Kontakt aufnehmen muss?
Nein, nein, wir werden immer jede Woche Kontakt haben. Das längste, was wir gemacht haben, wenn so eine Phase hinter der Sonne ist, dann hat man de facto keinen Kontakt. Aber bei BepiColombo dauert so eine Phase ungefähr einen Monat vielleicht, die längste. Die meisten sind kürzer. Und wenn wir in einer balistischen Phase sind, wo nichts passiert ist, und es ist gerade Weihnachten, vielleicht lassen wir auch einen Kontakt raus, sodass die Teams sich gut ausruhen können. Aber normalerweise werden wir schon jede Woche Kontakt haben, egal was passiert. Das ist zu gefährlich sonst. Wenn er ein Problem hat, zum Beispiel, und in seinen Basis Safe Mode geht, der Satellit, da benutzt er Treibstoff. Treibstoff ist ja eine sehr wichtige Ressource für uns. Wir können uns da nicht leisten, dass er zwei Wochen lang diesen Treibstoff benutzt, wo wir am Tag nachher das hätten finden können. Das geht gar nicht. Also wir gehen davon aus, dass mit einer Regelmäßigkeit von einer Woche, dann hat man eine gute Balance zwischen dem Workload für die Kollegen und der Sicherheit von Satelliten, dass er nicht in Moden geht, wo das nicht so gewünscht ist.
Also ich fange jetzt gerade an, so meine Termine für den August 2012 zu füllen. Was ist das für ein Gefühl, wenn man weiß, dass man die nächsten acht Jahre eigentlich eine regelmäßige Verabredung hat?
Ja, das war für meinen ersten Satellit, wo ich mit dem Start mitgemacht habe. Da war ich ein bisschen nervös. Ich dachte, naja, das ist schon eine riesen Verantwortlichkeit. Aber wenn man gesehen hat, was das eigentlich bedeutet, man ist ja nicht allein. Das ist eine richtige Teamarbeit und man kann sich gut verlassen. Diese Arbeit beruht nicht auf einem einzigen Individuum. Das ist sehr wichtig. Das ist sehr machbar und eigentlich nicht so intensiv, wie man sich das vorstellt, wenn man darüber spricht.
Ja, ich kann nur viel Glück wünschen. Lisa hat ja einen guten Track-Record, was die Interplanetarn-Mission betrifft. Von daher gibt es ja allen Anlass hier zu Optimismus.
Wir drücken die Daumen.
Gibt es noch einen Punkt, den du gerne beleuchten möchtest, den wir so noch nicht angesprochen haben? Super, dann sage ich vielen Dank für die Ausführung hier zu BepiColombo. In drei Jahren geht es los. Bis dahin, wenn wir uns hier das Thema Merkurs auf jeden Fall auch nochmal angenommen haben, wird aber nicht drei Jahre dauern, sondern relativ bald. Dann setzen wir dann auch schrittweise unsere Reise durch das Sonnensystem fort. In der Folge fliegt BepiColombo seine Bahnen. Wir fliegen jetzt auch unsere Bahnen. Ich sage Tschüss, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Bis bald bei Raumzeit.